my dearest sweet babies though you are
well aware that i am the most generous
of the theocratic fascist dictators out
there you may still be surprised by this
announcement we are releasing a bonus
installment in my patch program for the
month of june you heard that right i'm
giving you yet another reason to send me
your money over dailywire.com
shop and so i geniusly if that's even a
word dreamed up a few episodes back the
virtue signal patch i'm thinking do we
have a virtue signal i think we need a
patch that actually this is what this is
all about i mean we could kind of cover
everything all at once so maybe they're
maybe we should get a patch that just
says i don't know it just says virtue on
it or something or virtue signal and
just like with a wave of my hand it
materialized just like that the virtue
signal patch whether it's a blm fist
ukraine or the pride flag the virtual
signal patch will help you maintain the
moral high ground over the rest of
society you don't have to worry about
keeping up with the current thing
because you've got the virtue signal
patch and your virtue signaling and that
covers all of it okay it's a get out of
jail free card and you're good to go